[Music]
the prophet Muhammad s. wasam told us
that when the son of Adam dies all of
his Good Deeds are interrupted they are
finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a mid to convey The Message
of Islam is one of the best Deeds a
Muslim can do whenever someone prays
there whenever someone gives Shah in the
Masid whenever someone learns something
in the Masid yes that will be something
that you will have on your scale so give
generously and Allah will give you even
more
how are you guys doing I recently came
across a a video very disturbed
individual and he had this to
say but they were trying to call you a
pedo yesterday so some kids are really H
they dug in deep
oh it happened in the same day that I
was getting accused of wanting to kill
babies like wanted to snipe them or
whatever [__] Israel some babies are
really annoying but it's like how how
can how is it that we're both aligned
then if like you want to [__] rape
the kids and I want to kill them I'm a
necrophilic pedophile the holy [__] s
after you kill them I have my way with
them Jesus we could have had a better
response there could have incompatible
like how can I be killing them okay or
that oh well [__] it so what do you
think of that I thought that was that's
pretty normal if you're justifying a
genocide you're justifying men women
children being butchered in broad
daylight in front of the world to see I
think this is pretty much going to be
your fate this is going to be your
destiny what you expect isn't it from a
man like that I think he's being honest
I rate him for his honesty frankly yeah
because there are other people that are
hiding here and trying to be normal and
saying yeah we're just we're just like
you you know but we support genocide
this is just yeah I I dare him to make a
joke like that about Jewish kids whoa
yeah yeah yeah why not but but with
Palestinians it's a laugh it's a giggle
but with they them
it's anti-Semitism don't you know this
here oh yeah of course I thought you
were an
academic this guy here he makes me
sick I think he makes everyone sick but
I'm talking aboute his wife we well
let's talk about his let's talk about
his wife first I don't think he's got a
wife and I was told actually a reliable
source told me that he lets other men
have his have their way with his wife oh
damn cuz he was talking about having way
with kids you see in the end of the
video he was like you know I want to
have my way with kids and stuff like
that little babies that's all I think
the only ones that will give him any
attention well the only ones he can have
any dominance over have you seen the
have you seen the physical appearance of
this individual the word tweak comes to
mind the man is fragile in every way but
this individual you know he's coming on
talking about genocide talking like this
would you respect anyone who watches and
listens to this guy after this you know
we know where you stand in it to be
honest with you but this is something
symptomatic of something greater which
is now you're trying to
desensitize a Palestinian dehumanize
Palestinians to a point where we don't
even know really if you're joking or not
really your tone wasn't that explicitly
in a joking way anyway no but let's just
give some charity yeah if we are
charitable even though we're not
supposed to be charitable during what's
going on let's just say we
are why make jokes of Palestinians like
why trivialize something he don't care
he don't care he does not care
doesn't care bro people like this don't
care people like this do not care they
don't care about children They Don't
Care About Women they'll make these are
the same individuals that will come and
actually attack the religion of Islam
and talk about why it's against women's
rights and why it's against children's
rights this individual had I think he's
had a debate with
Daniel and he's had debates with Muslims
and he attacks Islam on moral grounds
that w w can you think about that for a
second this white sanctimonious man yeah
because of his European
nature and he's maybe he's a liberal
right he's coming to the religion of
Islam and he's saying that morally
you're inferior cuz one two and three
and then you're making jokes like
this this is somebody and and you're
justifying genocides don't come to us in
it don't come to us you're nothing
you're nothing it listen your voices
will never be accepted again I'm sorry
to say don't come to us with sanctimony
in it don't come to us with sanctimony
do you understand somebody like this
doesn't really have the moral ground to
be talking about anything pertaining
morals and it's somebody like this
that's best suited to be defending
Israel let be honest true he's the
perfect candidate that's being put
forward by Israel this this this is who
you need to lock arms with yeah well
continue with it um destiny continue
doing stuff like that cuz you know it's
it's not befitting for someone to
interrupt an enemy when is making a
mistake with that we'll conclude
wasam your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center this Center this Masid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even more